chess online is booming in only a couple
of weeks
hikaru and magnus will be competing in
the chess.com
speed chess championships which one of
those
fighters is going to take the top prize
over a hundred
thousand dollars in prize money in this
video we're going to take a look at
hikaru's
previous top five tactical moments
from chess.com competitions make sure
you like the video
and subscribe to the channel we're going
to start off with a nice and easy one
i like gradually getting you into the
action
like a lovely little curve up hill or
downhill whichever way you're going
here we see hikaru with the black pieces
placing against
the woman's top champion ho yifang
now this is a pattern i'm sure a lot of
you are familiar with but
what move now forced ho yifang to resign
and what is the correct checkmating
sequence here
i'm doing the eyebrow pay attention
i don't think i have eyebrows being
ginger but you get the idea
knight 2f2 check and this is the start
of one of the most
beautiful checkmates the smothered mate
we're gonna smother that white king in
pain
with our queen and knight combining
beautifully together
there's only one move king to g1 and now
knight to h3
double check and at this moment
well obviously ho yifan could see what
coming so she had already resigned
if the king goes to f1 that is checkmate
what i call the kiss of death checkmate
and the other way the king could go in
my eyes is even more pretty
and that is with the king going into the
corner where it will be trapped
as after queen to g1 oh yeah man
whatever captures that queen let's say
the rook
the knight slides into this square and
the white king
is entombed to this checkmate beautiful
stuff
well poor old ho yifang features twice
in my examples here nothing against you
fang
you're a fantastic player love the way
you play
unfortunately hikaru's just got some
beautiful finishes
against you now this position a little
bit harder than the last one
how did white force check mate here
in a very nice pattern again maybe not
too hard
we're keeping it a little bit easy today
so everyone can have a little go at the
checkmates
can you see it well first of all rook
takes g7 check yeah that's easy
i'm sure you saw that one two rooks on
the seventh rank is a very
powerful combination it's like having a
double barrelled shotgun
not a single one a double barrel one
king two h8
and what is the key move here the key
move
is now rook 2h7
check and this is a very pretty way to
finish the game
if the king goes to g8 then rook g7 is
mate
and if the knight captures the rook well
there's a number of ways to check mate
here
i'm only going to demonstrate one can
you see the other ways
knight to f7 double check it's that
queen and knight combining
so well together again and after
king to this square what checkmate you
want to play i always like checkmating
with the knight
because the knights one of my favorite
pieces knight takes h6
checkmate a demonstration of the power
of the two rooks and the queen of knight
well hikaru and magnus have
faced off against each other on numerous
occasions
and this is one encounter from the
chess.com
chess.com competition hikaru with the
white pieces
now plays a move which looks very
illogical
maybe this is not such a stunning
individual move by the looks of it but
it really is
beautiful d4
and this looks so weird because you're
blocking in
your prize piece your bishop on c3 but
it's what happens
next which is the idea behind this
hikaru is trying to release the other
bishop
if both of those guys get in the game
it's going to be
completely hopeless for magnus who has
the black pieces
magnus tries bishop to d8 and here is
the idea
d5 that pawn has to be captured
and now queen to e5 and you can see this
little pawn
advance has really demonstrated the
power of the two
bishops d4 was tried the bishop slides
in
and after king f7 bishop takes d4
and black's position is hopeless the
queen is aiming to come
into a square like g7 and these bishops
just dominate everything a very nice win
for hikaru over magnus
magnus has had his fair share of wins
who's going to win in a couple of weeks
time
do place your bets below hikaru seems to
be faring very
well recently at top level but he's got
to keep it up
against well the world champion of
course you may have noticed there's a
bit of a theme
in the tactics that i have picked today
and in this one we see wesley sew
with the white pieces playing against
hikaru and now it's hikaru to move
and to force a deadly attack i have to
say
it's a funky night and queen day today
what did hikaru do can you see the
winning
idea well he now plays rook
takes b4 and this is the move to clear
up that diagonal for the queen
and use his two knights and queen to
weave
a checkmate net against wesley's king
this has to be captured the queen now
gets on the important diagonal with a
major
check and really here white
has no defense wesley tried king to h1
had the queen been met this check by
king to f1
well i think a move such as knight to h5
would be
good enough that knight comes into g3
but after king to h1 the next move is
the important one
again knight coming to this square is
good but there's an even more forcing
move
and that is oh yeah
knight takes e4 it's always nice
to play a capture rather than a silent
move
the knight again is threatening to come
into g3 with checkmate
there's no good way to stop this move
and
after queen takes e4 knight to f2 won
wesley so
and the game as well knight and queen
power in action
well the last example comes about in the
ending
a lot of people may get a bit complacent
in the last part of the game thinking
how it's an
ending boring i'm gonna go and have a
little nap wake me up when it's a draw
but in actual fact the ending can often
result in
crazy tactics yet again ho yifang
is on the receiving end of some naka
magic here
but what move now allowed hikaru to
create a deadly breakthrough
g5 this is a beautiful way to create a
pass pawn
on the h file this is stage one of the
tactical
sequence now ho yifang took that pawn
otherwise
hikaru would have just gone g takes h6
and now the point is
h6 getting near to queening
the black king has to try and stop that
and what is part two of the tactic
part two is b6 a lovely
two-sided combination here now the b
pawn
is threatening to storm down the board
and ho yifang had to give up her bishop
but after bishop takes d6 it's a
hopeless situation
the h pawn is still too strong hikaru
has that extra piece
lovely lovely tactical vision there be
by hikaru
it's going to be very interesting to see
how he faces off against magnus
what do you guys think do leave your
comments below in the chat
is hikaru gonna take the first prize and
be the 2020 chess.com
speed chess champion i don't know it's
going to be close
i'm looking forward to watching so we
have some crisp and nice tactics there
from hikaru who is
deadly online he seems to be getting
better and better just look at his
results
in the chess.com titled tuesday event
i don't know if he's going to be able to
get through magnus but i'm going to be
watching it
as i'm sure most of you guys are as well
remember like this video
subscribe to the channel and we're going
to be watching some of magnus's
most amazing news very soon